[Musik]
es ist eine WM wie es sie noch nie gab
gekauft gebaut mit Atem beraubendem
Reichtum unser heftig kritisiert wie
keine zuvor kurz vor Beginn der Spiele
eskaliert nun der Streit vor ein paar
Tagen etwa der Chef von Katha airwacer
öffnet ein neues Terminal einen grünen
Luxus für einfliegende Fußballfans und
verliert bei kritischen Fragen dann kurz
die Fassung
wie Sie sehen können gibt es eine
negative Medienkampagne gegen mein
geliebtes Land Katar
die Menschen können nicht akzeptieren
dass ein kleines Land wie der Stadt
Katha das größte Sportereignis der Welt
gewonnen hat
lange hat Katha für sich geworben mit
teurem Lobbying mit Verbesserungen für
Wanderarbeiter die unter auf dieser
streusen Bedingungen die Stadien Bauten
kurz vor der WM aber verhärtet sich der
Ton und zeigt damit umso deutlicher dass
die Lämmer Deutschlands das auf Werte
pocht aber Energie braucht
wenn sie Faser ist nur ein Beispiel die
Innenministerin findet die WM-Vergabe
nach katawan Fehler Kartoffeln
in Katha will Faeser
Sicherheitsgarantien für deutsche Fans
und glaubt dass sie die vom
Premierminister auch bekommen hat
gesagt dass er alles dafür tun wird dass
die Sicherheit der Menschen garantiert
wird und auch zwar mit dieser
Formulierung egal an wen man glaubt egal
wie man liebt egal wo man herkommt kaum
aber ist sie zurück werden in einer
zdf-doku schwulenfeindliche Äußerungen
von Katas wm-botschafter bekannt
es ist taram also verboten aber warum
ist es heran es ist ein geistiger
schaden
wie viel ist die Sicherheitsgarantie da
noch wert
Fässer glaubt weiter daran aber ob sie
zum ersten Spiel der Nationalmannschaft
fährt klingt nicht mehr so sicher ich
werde schauen ob ich das hinkriege
nächste Woche dann zu reisen
in der Ampel jedenfalls wächst der Druck
auf die Innen- und Sportministerin der
WM fernzubleiben wenn wir sozusagen
Sicherheitsgarantien aussprechen müssen
für eine Sportveranstaltung dann ist es
doch offensichtlich dass dieses Land
nicht dafür gemacht ist meine
persönliche Meinung ist dass wir
diplomatisch boykottieren sollten das
Kabinettsmitglieder nicht reisen sollten
dass Dilemma aber ist größer ist der
Fußball deutschland braucht Katar im
Sommer vergangenen Jahres Katha soll die
Taliban überzeugen Menschen aus
Afghanistan flüchten zu lassen
im März kommt Habeck
im September Schulz diesmal lautet die
Bitte Katha soll helfen das Gas aus
Russland zu ersetzen
[Musik]
wir können nicht einerseits feststellen
dass unser Wirtschaftsminister hinfährt
und dort lng-gas kauft das auch noch
großartig findet und dann auf der
anderen Seite jetzt so tun als wenn wir
dieses Land komplett meiden könnten oder
wollten also wir müssen schon einen
nüchterne einheitliche Positionen
gegenüber und in Katar einnehmen
auch der Fußball lässt Faser
kühlauflaufen FIFA Präsident Infantino
lobt sich und die FIFA
Menschenrechtspolitik doch kaum sind die
Deutschen Weg forderte in einem Brief
Schluss mit der Politik konzentrieren
wir uns jetzt auf den Fußball
es ist wie ein Vorgeschmack auf den
nächsten Konflikt die
Europameisterschaft 2024 in Deutschland
noch hofft die Ampel dass da alles
besser wird du müssen wir deutlich
machen dass Sport und Politik kein
Gegensatz sind sondern natürlich ganz
viel damit zu tun haben dass das
Gesellschaftspolitik ist was im Sport
passiert und dass die Menschenrechte
absolut unteilbar sind allerdings die
UEFA liest das Innenministerium schon
wissen über die Teilnahme von Putin
Verbündeten wie Belarus entscheidet nur
die UEFA
Berlin mag Werte fordern wird am Ende
aber wohl doch nur zuschauen